hey everyone how's it going my name is
miyuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech career and
life i know it doesn't really look it
though but we're baking today because
this is an edition of muco's corner
where i talk about software engineering
career advice basically
and today's topic is about how to decide
when to leave your software engineering
job
i myself have left four jobs in total in
the last six years
and each one of them i've kind of gained
some more
insight and wisdom into how to go about
doing it
and so i wanted to share that with you
so share my personal experiences and
talk about what i think about
when i'm thinking about leaving a job
all right so let's get started we are
making
shoe cream puffs today i literally
haven't made this
since like i was in high school so this
could actually end very terribly
but i'm using someone else's recipe so
i'll link it down the description box
down below
so i guess let's get started and we're
off to the races everybody
so yeah let's dive into the topic so how
do you know it's time to leave your job
basically
and to answer that i kind of wanted to
bring up the whole thing about a value
exchange
so basically are you getting what you
put into your job
out of your job it's a really fine
balance to achieve because the answer is
literally different for everyone in
every job
and so in order to answer that you have
to first figure out
what do you want from a job i literally
haven't used this like
condo gas range thing whatever you call
it in english for anything
other than like hot butt so
it's kind of interesting to actually be
using it for cooking to be honest with
you so we'll see how it goes
so first you have to figure out what do
you want from your job and i'm going to
give you some examples because
i think it's helpful to know what you
could get out of a job and this is based
on what i like getting out of a job what
i've heard other people like getting it
out of a job and it'll kind of bring
some tangibility into this whole thing
you know
while we're on the topic of leaving jobs
a big part about
leaving a job and finding a new one is
building your skill set
which is why i wanted to say thank you
to the sponsor of today's video
skillshare skillshare is a platform that
offers
thousands of inspiring classes for
creative and curious people
with classes and everything from python
to illustration
to architecture to brand work skillshare
classes include
a combination of video lessons and a
class project
and they're made to fit your schedule
and skill level members get unlimited
access to
thousands of classes and most are under
60 minutes
if you've decided to leave your job you
know that what's next is interviewing at
other companies
and so there's actually a really great
course on skillshare called
master the coding interview algorithms
and data structures to help you brush up
on your interviewing skills
it's actually a really thorough class it
goes through things like your resume
linkedin profile portfolio and then
it'll kind of give you a refresher on
fundamental computer science concepts
and all of the algorithms and data
structures that typically show up in a
software engineering interview
it's a really popular course and
skillshare has a ton of classes like
this
on their platform so only the first 1000
people to click the link in the
description box down below will get a
free trial of skillshare premium
make sure to check that out and thank
you again to skillshare for sponsoring
now let's get back to the video so one
big thing is compensation are you
getting paid for the work that you put
in and you know everybody uses that
money a different way some people need
to support a family or loved ones other
people
want to buy property and increase their
wealth and you know retire by 45
other people want to use it just to get
by whatever that might be for you
basically
the next one that a lot of people talk
about is opportunities to grow and learn
new skill sets so whether that mean a
new skill set and like a new technology
or just new communication skills or some
people like it because they want to
learn
and become like a manager or rise up the
ranks then stir in one cup flour
using a wooden spoon okay i don't have a
wooden spoon so guess what i'm gonna use
i'm gonna use a freaking rice paddle
okay
you know rice paddle worked very well
uncle roger would be very pleased
i'm actually not much of a baker most of
my knowledge really is just from
watching lots of british bake off
all right other things you can get from
a job networking opportunities so
ability to connect with people that you
want to because you admire them or
because they're going to level up your
career even more
or because you just like connecting with
people some people also want flexibility
from their jobs so that could be
hours that could be location other
people also look for benefits so things
like
health care stocks anything that's not
exactly
monetary that comes with a compensation
package another one that i really look
for in a job is fulfillment in your work
i mean some people are okay with not
that but i feel like it's a lot of time
to spend on something
so i'd rather have it bring me like
inherent joy and fulfillment
than not so another one could be a
harmonious like work environment or
culture
because maybe you want to work for
somewhere that you really align with its
mission or that you really enjoy
working with other people whatever that
might mean to you so yeah those are all
examples of what you could get from a
job
and that's important because you need to
figure that out before you can
understand am i getting like a fair
value exchange between
me and my job like is the work that you
do for a company
and for an app and the code that you
write like are you getting
those other things back as a result so
basically then you gotta ask yourself
after you evaluate what you want from
your job and what it means to you like
all of this also changes over time what
i want from a job now is different from
what i wanted from a job two years ago
even but yeah ask yourself
are you getting all of this from your
current job like what are you putting in
as a result
and it's a balance this is really kind
of more of an art than a science because
calibrating fair is like kind of tough
thing to do so it's important to stay
attuned to this and figure out what
fair means to you and that allows you to
kind of see the whole equation
as a result so yeah first i do that
evaluation am i getting out
what i put into my job and sometimes the
immediate answer is like
no no way like you're not getting
anything out of it but i think another
important part of all this which i've
realized over my career is
maybe you're not getting the right
balance maybe it's not fair right now
but
will it be in the future figure out if
maybe you're gonna get this in the
future because
short-sightedness can bite you
especially in today's economy
and also it's not about just like
hopping from job to job
like it's about learning what you can
from a job seeing what you can get out
of it and then once you feel like you've
got everything you can get out of it
then you graduate
i think to the next job you know like in
tara's house where like
everybody graduates out i kind of think
about it like that
it's like you quit a job but also you
graduate from it
is this the most asian choux pastry
you've ever seen or what did you know
that when you're making mashed potatoes
instead of using a masher
it's actually really efficient to use a
rice paddle this is something i realized
in college
like rice paddle can do so many things
it's important to have one
and very handy so yeah maybe you're
gonna get some of these things later
down the road after you put in more of
an initial investment to your work or
maybe there's opportunities that are
gonna open up in the future because of
some
reorg that's coming because of some
manager that's coming because
i don't know maybe you're just gonna
feel like you're more used to the job
and it's not as scary and daunting
anymore and you feel like you can stick
it out for a little longer
because probably most of my jobs the
first month i'm like i
hate this job i can't do anything i want
to quit i'm so bad at it i don't deserve
it and so i always need to ride out that
wave
probably like a good three to six month
wait for me to get to a point where i'm
like oh okay
like now i can see what i'm getting out
of the job so be patient
and maybe it's not obvious to you like
when those opportunities are going to
come for you to
actually get what you want out of your
job and that's honestly a conversation
you can have with your manager
because then your manager can kind of
keep a look out because they likely know
more of how the company works and what
opportunities might come your way
and they can assign projects and things
to you and have you work with certain
people
to kind of broaden your horizons and
open your perspectives
i always try to explore as many options
as possible before
i really even allow myself to make a
decision
and just like the scientific method of
just being like i'll try
this thing because i was presented with
this opportunity
and then i expect to get these results
from it and then you do it and then you
see if the results were accurate
is one way to kind of like project your
future
opportunities as well as what your
future at the company and job might look
like and then sometimes i do these
projections and then as they do more and
more of these
i kind of get a sense of like okay this
is a general area in which i'm headed
and then it's just still not very
exciting to me
this is actually kind of what happened
at netflix to be honest i was there for
like
a solid year in a couple of months and
i definitely tried my best to give it
the opportunity to
be open-minded to what i could learn but
i think towards the end of that year
i started seeing like okay if i stay at
this job here are
kind of the things that i could see
playing out here the different
journeys that i could take and i was
still just like i don't
really care to do that honestly like i
could have become this like all-knowing
super badass like ios engineer who knows
the ins and outs of the netflix app
and really well connected to other
netflix engineers and managers
and to some people that's great like i
think that's an honestly very
good honest piece of work that is really
exciting to some folks but at the time
i was really interested in content
creation i was like what is it like to
be your own boss what is it like
to build your own business and connect
with the people that i've always wanted
to connect with including you so yeah
that's
kind of a big reason why i was like you
know i could stick it out for longer but
i just don't see myself
really being excited by these prospects
[Music]
tired ta-da it's not very much i'm
actually only just making half we're
doing good
so now you get that there's like this
value exchange between you
and your job and maybe you've identified
what you want from your job and then you
thought about
okay am i getting this from my job right
now will i get this from my job
and really the next thing to do i think
is to talk to your manager
and obviously you don't want to tell
your manager like yo i'm thinking of
leaving my job
do something because that doesn't really
put them in a good spot because they are
responsible for you and your employment
so an alternative way to telling them
that you're not getting what you want
out of your job
is to kind of tell them hey this is
something that i'm looking for in my
role here
and i just don't really quite feel like
i'm getting it like what can we do
or what can i do in order to work on
that and yeah it's a
uncomfortable conversation especially if
it's something around compensation which
is a lot harder
because your pay is not just determined
by your managers determined by
the budget and your financial planning
and kind of all that stuff
yo if this works i will be so dang happy
not just because it worked but because
i'll be rewarded
with shoe cream what are these called
cream puffs americans call them clean
puffs
japanese you call them shoe creams tada
look at my shoe it looks pretty good huh
anyway yeah talk to your manager
i think it's the most effective thing
it's also the most courteous thing to
have them be a part of the conversation
to give you what you need from a job i
mean they're also going to be the people
who are going to evaluate whether
the company and the team is getting what
it needs from you as well but having
them be a part of the conversation to
make sure that
they are doing whatever they can to help
you grow that's kind of like the core
part of a manager's job i think
although there's a twist there's
actually a saying about how people leave
managers not companies because maybe you
want to talk to your manager or you've
been talking to your manager about
getting what you need
and given that they're the people who
are most responsible for you who can
most help you out
if they're not doing that for you that's
really hard it makes it like a thousand
times harder like you could rely on
other people to get what you need
maybe it's another manager on the same
team or
mentors for instance or maybe you're
really close to
another manager or director or something
or maybe even peers
but ultimately software engineers
employment and experience
i think is really heavily affected by
managers
luckily for me i've been so blessed and
so fortunate to have
incredible managers at every company so
i've never left a company
because of a manager but there are tons
of people
who i know work at silicon valley
companies startups and stuff who leave
because their manager isn't very good
for those of you who bake you know how
some people are like you should whip
your cream until you get stiff peaks i
think you should
cream until it kind of resembles like a
puffer fish
mating ritual like the little sand thing
that they make and when you can start
seeing that on the outside i feel like
that's
that's when it's done anyway that's kind
of how i think about
how you know it's time to leave your job
how to navigate that whole like oh maybe
i should quit
my job kind of feeling i'm sure there's
other ways to navigate this too so again
share with me your experiences and what
you think about when you're about to
leave a job
in the comments down below the shoe
creams are not done
but i am done with the topic so if you'd
like to see
the rest of them being made and the
final state then keep on watching but
otherwise thank you so much for watching
the video i wanted to make a video on
this topic for a while because
a lot of people have room requesting it
and it's something that i think
is on everybody's mind at some point in
their career so i hope it helps you and
if it did
consider subscribing i have other
episodes of mooco's corner where i talk
about software engineering career tips
and tricks
in the playlist down below and i hope
you check them out i hope all of you are
doing well wherever you are even though
the world is
kind of crazy right now hope you have a
great day wherever you are and take care
everybody
[Music]
bye
done it looks pretty dang good
that's really good i made that yo
i got a lot out of that because you know
the work
you put in what you get out of it
alright see you in the next video fam
bye